where are you now Addison I'm still in
Chicago in my apartment packing up ready
to head back home are you able to walk
the streets in Chicago lease on the
north side uh no not really
I have people outside my apartment
sometimes now that we won the World
Series you know just kind of waiting to
get my autograph because I live so close
to the ball field what would surprise me
in your apartment uh all the kids toys
in this place Wayman oh oh so wait hell
just hold your child my son is 15 15
months old yeah does he have a batting
stance can he does he have his own glove
no he has a few bad he's starting to
learn how to run a little bit he's still
a little bit wobbly on his feet but but
I he gets the point A to point B all
right can he run faster than David Ross
nah David Roscoe has it's close though
right yeah yeah it's pretty close
how would you recap the last week if
somebody didn't know what happened and
you were trying to sum up what did
happen how would you start oh man he's
just a whirlwind a lot of doubt in
people's mind but obviously we worked
hard all year we had some fun along the
way
just to see you know the Cubs unite a
whole city after 108 years and come back
to the World Series has just been a
whirlwind you know all the fans support
then again we had the parade as well
here in Chicago and that was like the
seventh largest human gathering in all
of history just seeing that and being on
those buses and waving to everyone
seeing all the smiles on everyone's
faces that was pretty crazy but just
going through the whole game experience
too was was nuts coming back from a
three to one deficit to the Cleveland
Indians
and winning three games in a row to come
out on top and that's just something
very memorable and something that
shouldn't be taken lightly because a lot
of hard works behind that what was the
feeling like as you look out over that
crowd at Grant Park oh man it was just a
lot of joy a lot of a lot of joy a lot
of smiles a lot of happy people you know
we got a chance to unite a whole city
and and that we got to share that with a
whole buncha cago and so me myself I was
elated
I was excited just to see all the
different colors to see all the
beautiful people out there and all the
support it was awesome if you this Jason
Heyward speech that was given during the
rain delay how important like was it
just something where he just said come
on everybody let's go into the weight
room and then you guys didn't know what
was going on or what to expect um we
kind of myself I kind of had a feeling
that I thought we needed a pep talk and
J hay has been one of the one of the
leaders on our team that that uh
everyone seems to listen to the the
easiest and he just after they put the
tarp on we all went into the weight room
and he called us all in there and was
like hey guys I just like to share some
my mind then he opened up and was like
yo y'all we worked so hard for all of
this and and here we are game seven they
they just came back but you know we've
we've been through this stuff before you
know so don't get down on yourself you
know we had a few people down on
themselves but we are a team and we pick
each other up and we have been doing
that all all season long and and J hey
he just gave us a good reminder you know
that we're family and we pick each other
up whenever each other's going down and
and he gave us a nice little speech talk
and after that you know it was off to
the races uh score two runs following
inning so it did some kind of good and
just to see him kind of take the team
and under his wing and and make us all
feel that way and remind us you know
that it was such a long journey really
hit home to all of us I think it might
have been the most important rain rain
delay in baseball history Addison
because I thought you guys were on the
ropes there with you know the Davis home
run and you know just it felt like it
allowed you guys to hit the reset button
and then win it in the 10th inning yeah
absolutely I think that i think that
that rain delay had a lot to do with us
winning and then also Jake speech it was
a beautiful speech or not and that we
get out there and yeah it's history now
so I'm just happy to be a part of it
he's Addison Russell joining us on
behalf of metrics whose lineup of sports
nutrition protein bars ready-to-drink
beverages helping athletes take their
training to the next level there's
anything you'd like to add to that
Addison the stage is yours
yeah well been working hard all year
it's starting at Spring Training I
needed to put to prepare myself to get
ready for these big moments
so I partnered with metrics to make sure
my workouts are on point they really
helped my training go to the next level
and that it helps on my body and it
makes me feel good after a workout I've
been using it all year and it feels
great what's a bad pregame meal I would
say I would say Taco Bell or McDonald's
yeah that's stuff kind of stick stuff
kind of sticks but but I normally eat
like a protein bar like I eat their big
10 100 protein bar and and it's the
perfect amount of fuel for me so I get
out and do the things I need to do and
then after my workout you know I slam a
protein shake to recover quickly so I'm
all covered there but McDonald's
McDonald's for sure Taco Bell's probably
not the best which of your teammates is
still partying oh man
I think I think Anthony Rizzo's
he's been on a few talk shows he's ready
to live it up is is Rizzo your Rob
Gronkowski from the Patriots absolutely
absolutely that's a great way to put it
did you say did they allow you to keep
the bat from the Grand Slam or did you
get that ball back or do anything that
you kept from the World Series yeah I
kept basically everything I didn't get
the ball back um I kept the bat I got it
I got it all syndicated and everything
it's it's in my locker right now yeah I
kept the cleats the baton blows all all
that game 7 stuff yeah you have to keep
that stuff man it's there's memorabilia
stuff that I think that my kid will have
a kick out of seeing whenever I'm old
and dusty so well who knows what it's
gonna smell like though Addyson by the
time you open it up for your son right
yeah you know yeah yeah definitely me
the cases uh sure
hey congrats and good luck on promoting
metrics today and thanks for joining us
good luck with the move Thank You Danny
I appreciate that's Addison Russell Cubs
shortstop the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience